greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday May 8 the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by
ProFlowers don't forget to thank the
real pros this Mother's Day which is
Sunday [ __ ] it's coming up May
12th do not forget where would you be
without your mom what would you be you'd
be nowhere number 1 my mom is dead so
we're cool to us and the flowers to the
cemetery but number 2 I do have a
special mom and that's my wife Teri
I gotta hook her up in fact me mercy
gonna get her a few gifts we're gonna go
to plural ProFlowers and send the two
dozen flowers cuz that's how we roll you
understand me
right now you get a dozen assorted roses
for $19.99 again that's $19.99 double
the roses and get a premium vazh for
just $9.99 more that's it it's that easy
if you love your mother you send her the
roses and you go over and hang out if
you don't love your mother you keep an
arm distance you still send her the
roses then you tell me you can't come
over because you got the Chinese flu
that's it it's that easy it all starts
with you go to proflowers.com click the
microphone on the upper right corner and
at the promo code Church that's
proflowers.com the church is also
brought to you by zip recruiter
saving you time energy and money why
Joey because it's hard to find qualified
candidates it takes a long time too many
applicants and zip recruiter will make
it easier than peasy it you understand
me
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
with them one day that saves your time
that saves your money that saves you
everything you understand me and
humiliation so do me a favor right now
the church family could go to zip
recruiter for free Joey what are you
talking about I'm talking about free
when was the last time somebody gave you
something for free
nothing gratis just cuz you're part of
the family right now for free go to zip
Rikuo calm slash Church CH you are CH if
you don't watch Sesame Street CH you are
CH that zipper crew
dot-com / church the church is also
brought to you by listen someone's
coming everybody wants to have a hot
woman okay what good is it if you meet a
hot woman when she goes down I need your
dick smells like a [ __ ] swamp of debt
because you haven't shaved nothing you
know powder your balls you think you're
[ __ ] James Bond but you ain't you
[ __ ] your boss stink like [ __ ] debt
and why cuz you got that Bush around
them I ain't mad at the bush you got a
trim it you understand me and that's
what manscape comes in me myself I don't
like nobody likes trimming that dick
it's too close to home I'm mother's well
you have I might I want you to stab me
in the [ __ ] heart before you trim
your dick but you ever look at your dick
I see the bush that's growing around it
nobody wants to see that [ __ ] uncle
Joey's here to tell you listen you're
not gonna cut your dick off the
suffering ends today no more anxiety
which man with manscape you get it done
without the pain the [ __ ] my dicks
gonna get cut off I'm gonna be hanging
out with Bobbitt no that [ __ ] dumbwit
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels manscaped has redesigned the
electric razor with the invention of the
lawnmower you understand me a hand he'll
raise it with skin-safe technology
it won't Niklas nag that [ __ ] nut
sack or the peanuts dick now right now
the church family gets 20% off your
first order when you use promo code
Church they're 20% off your first order
when you press in church at manscape
calm and if you order the perfect
package which we'll talk about later
they'll throw in a free travel bag on
the arm which is tremendous it's in my
bag right now I got the warp ball wipe I
got everything in there in case you bump
into a [ __ ] Anonymous tray
they want to join Scientology go to
manscape com use promo code church and
get 20% off your first order keep your
balls clean-cut suckers mule I mean you
take this [ __ ] beer league it was last
time somebody drank your juice I really
do need to you need to drink that juice
I need to drink your juice I'm afraid
I'm a t-shirt
your freedom I don't know I've gotten to
a place where I I feel a little afraid
of dating now because I haven't dated
since November and everything has been
pretty calm I mean until a couple you've
got some dates you just I've been on a
couple dates yeah right dates I'll go on
one or two and then this is me show me
anything no no I don't just show any big
homerun than nothing
honestly my thing is they can touch
whatever but once I'm naked I'm going to
[ __ ] them I can't you can't get naked
and not have sex how bowls is there a
date somebody in the first date they
play games here what do you mean [ __ ]
you listen I won't do that see I won't
do that
episode law and order come on don't be
five minutes you suck this me Liga vamos
I had a girl come over took her shirt
off stayed the night sucked it but
wouldn't take her she slept on her jeans
why was she on her period I don't know
did you ask no touch I took over the
jeans but yeah why didn't you take come
on what would you do she had a big black
[ __ ]
Joey surprising she was but you busy
picking up a storm for a week no way
wait but why didn't did you ask her to
take her pants I wasn't comfortable yet
but she came over at midnight and she
took so oh she came at midnight for the
first day yeah see I've never done this
[ __ ] guy meets chicks on tendon they
turn them that one one of they take it
slow well he caught me they say goes you
met her on tinder but she wanted to take
it slow
yeah they all say that all times they
mean it no they don't I mean it when I
say what I'm on tinder I do it back on
tinder but I don't [ __ ] I don't like
just have sex
here's the problem I'm you know I'm like
really sexual but I'm really picky so I
don't get naked with them too I'm sure
that I want to like date them
but once I'm naked we're [ __ ] there's
no in-between for me there's no like
there's no stop at third base yeah yes I
[ __ ] play black-blue bore me to death
you already took your clothes off yeah
but lately it's happened twice that I've
met great guys and like when they're
into me I
anok and i like run away because I'm
afraid that I'm gonna [ __ ] up their life
somehow that's really true like I'm
afraid that probably well if you're that
upfront but what are you really is
afraid of that you my genome that you
might know I've never cheated something
awkward I mean what are you really
afraid of I think what it really is
honestly is that I broke my ex-husband's
heart so bad that I think I'm just
scared of doing that to someone else but
listen how many times that these idiots
broke your [ __ ] heart so many times I
think I think that's the whole reason
like you were giving me [ __ ] about the
guys that I pick and you're right but I
think the reason is like on some level I
think it's because I know if anyone gets
hurt it'll be me which is stupid I'm
trying to fix it but that's why I
haven't dated since November and since
the last thing was kind of traumatic and
I just haven't really got back out there
girls in my life I've been to girls who
are promiscuous and I'm gonna tell you
how I feel about cuz I've never talked
about this before on a podcast cuz it
bothers me how I feel about this I was
raised Catholic and I was raised in a
very special place you know I know girls
who have been with two guys because I
known since they were 10 I know a girl
that's been with the same guy from
[ __ ] high school yeah me too most of
the girls I grew up with with two guy
girls yeah they'd [ __ ] the guy in high
school he took their virginity they left
them when they threw a football at him
and then they hooked up with another guy
now they've been married for 20 [ __ ]
years
well that's how I was I was a virgin
never understood I didn't really know
game was just very very I love it dearly
was still friends
yeah but she's very bad news and I would
look at her naked and I remember there
were some nights that I would feel bad
for her because I didn't understand if
she knew how beautiful she was now
special herb I'm sure she doesn't didn't
what a girl comes to me
and says the guy at work we giggle we
have a laugh well inside my heart breaks
because somewhere there's a guy that got
the best idea yeah but I've masturbated
in front of him and he ate my butt
that's all great but somewhere there's a
guy with a story somewhere that's why I
don't know Thalia Greeley story that's
why I'm always afraid to I've always
wanted woman to have a little bit more
respect for themselves because somewhere
there's a [ __ ] slob like me you're
not story I could not live with that if
I was a woman I know what you mean I did
not live with that I know I gave I mean
I'm full obviously beautiful little
[ __ ] [ __ ] between my legs that was
that good that made a man feel that good
I'd be so [ __ ] selective and the main
thing would be because I don't want a
mother [ __ ] to have a story about me
well I'm that way with like comedy club
employees people I'm that way on the
road like I don't want anybody to have a
story that's why I never go out with
like I mean I hate to say it but like I
never really go out with like fans after
shows and stuff because I just know I
don't want something like that to be
left behind I mean obviously you will
listen Italian Italian yeah we make
mistakes I have a dear friend who's
solid as a comic and she told me when
she first started she took a guy home
and she really enjoyed him they said
friends for her but it became
uncomfortable for us she couldn't do it
anymore shouldn't get into comedy to do
that you know we all make mistakes we
all make mistakes
I just thought that you know I have a
daughter now nobody was [ __ ] more than
me I love easy but I've always one day
we were having a joke and Joe Rogan's
those yeah anybody you ever date killed
himself
I said serious I know they should if you
suck my dick
I can't imagine sucking myself and
seeing that one ball that's [ __ ] my
balls like what's-his-name they got like
you know like the
Marty feminised I know what they look
like horrible I feel bad for and I'm not
saying this as a joke like I feel bad if
you got drunk one night and we hooked up
like today I think about you I'm with
yes I do
but you were like an animal it sounds
like you were great doesn't matter what
I was an animal you shouldn't you know
what I was it's a truth though these
women are married to a nice guy now they
have kids and one night when they
holding their kid they're looking
through Netflix and there's a picture of
me talking about stupidity and they
gotta go back and go [ __ ]
I suck this dick in the bathroom or to
the bar but you know what I bet they
hold that memory and a happy place
there's no guy I've ever slept with
there's one or two that I regret but
they're ones that I actually dated but
there's never been a guy that I did have
that kind of a circumstance with where
it was like a fling or like a one-night
thing that I regretted because it's
happened so rarely that in my mind
they're kind of like a fun exciting like
wow that's rare for me so it's a it's a
cool memory even if I threw up on him or
something bad happened it's still in my
head like a fun that story that I have I
had a friend in Seattle a comic friend
she doesn't do comedy no more we were
open Mica's together I never fooled
around with her nothing and like that
she drove to gigs she was really cool
with it yeah she always brought weed and
I remember one morning she was like a
rampage we were talking about something
Alki Beach I'll never forget this one
okay and there was a I'll kind breakfast
spot where I used to see how do you
better oh well I better we'll eat there
laughs at the time this is 95 this is 20
whatever years and I'll never forget her
telling me the story once and this is
what I was I wasn't ready for this [ __ ]
these kind of stories from women yeah
like what'd you end up doing the LA cuz
we used to go to a bar on Monday nights
there was Seattle calmly on the ground
and then half of us would go to a bar in
the artistic area and there would be
go-go bar dancers and
cages uh-huh and she was pretty hot she
was cute she was I she was just young
and
I always thought she had it together
until this one morning that we were
talking I don't know what happened to
you that night like I hadn't seen it or
like five days ago
we were all together what happened you
you left her stand she's like I gotta
say it what happened oh my god that she
went into this whole thing now the
bartender reminded her of a boyfriend in
high school and she couldn't forget
about a boyfriend so she waited for the
guy and she asked him for his number and
then she went home and she waited and I
won't call him at 3 in the morning and
went over there she brought a dildo and
all this [ __ ] I'm like she told me this
in my head's about to blow I was like me
three years ago and she goes she brought
a dildo and the guy put put the dildo in
her ass and I'm sitting there with my
other buddy and I'm just like my other
buddies digging it and I'm laughing
along with it but at the same time on
the inside you're like oh just look at
all the girl doesn't know she's at 12'o
this girl doesn't know that she could
move to LA right now and get on a cover
of any major magazine and listen to me
you're not gonna believe this story we
sat down long enough like we're there
for Mike and I go why did this guy live
and she goes it's so funny the reason
why I'm telling you the story is because
he lived a couple blocks from here and
five minutes later the guy walked by
with a girl holding a hand walking his
dog oh well he was really skinny and he
was let me tell you something I'm no
[ __ ] Almar the [ __ ] model but this
guy was not a good-looking guy by no
means he was skinny dirty jeans on and
I'll never forget the look on her face
she wasn't there I don't know what year
it was nice to remember the story that
I'm gonna write for my daughter that's
sad because she just told us about a
pretty intense sexual thing that it
would have to take me a month of doing
coke with you to go into I mean he put
the dildo in her ass and taped her and
took pictures of her taped her yo I
can't tied her up like tape dirt Oh tape
film her Polaroid shots of her oh wow
and now there he is walk
and let me tell you something if you
know anything about me I got this guy's
number this is how crazy I am about that
stuff topic I got his number at the bar
yeah I would call the ball no oh yeah
let's say his name was RAM all right
I'm looking for your [ __ ] I'm
gonna break yet and I'd hang up and I
found that he was a music promoter and
other bars so I got his number phone for
his house I love that and I would
torment them the girl never knew nobody
knew I just know that's amazing how
crazy it was I moved to LA and I would
still call him in Seattle so cuz I never
just a [ __ ] with them just to let him
know I was watching him oh [ __ ] is this
I got a dog and I would sit on the phone
that's amazing how crazy I am I love
guys like that though that's how great
cuz he was such a [ __ ] puke and this
girl didn't know what she was getting
herself into I would have [ __ ] her and
came into my meeting a [ __ ] and licked
her [ __ ] that's one thing he he
treated her like a [ __ ] dog like I
know okay which we dead dog better shame
on her so let them do these things to
her I mean I made by the same time I
hope that she's somewhere right now
holding the kid and this comes into a
mine thank you go through phases because
I feel like I've changed a lot and I
feel like that's been part of actually
like I mean we talked about this but I
feel like I've been kind of going
through a weird time of my life just
because I feel like I've changed like
I'm a lot more calm I'm not partying as
much I'm not hooking up I'm not dating
I'm not doing as many like bikini photos
and just I feel like it different I feel
like I've grown up I've just grown up
some and also I've become funnier and I
don't feel like I need as many ways to
get attention and whatever but I feel
like people still associate all that
with me so it's been a weird time of
like kind of you know trying to show
people like it's not show people it's
just being myself has become a little
more difficult because the people that
are used to that Kate are like well
what's going on like they're waiting for
that I go on the road and people like
still in a
do drugs or you know think it's gonna be
crazy and it's just it's not like I've
been doing drugs at all not much every
once in a while but like once a month
versus you know all the time yeah yeah
it's really weird how
I like when comedy becomes a religion
for you yeah I like when something
becomes a religion for you that now
you're doing some things outside that
realm to better your comic just you got
on stage all you want you get on stage
all you want become a great comic but
it's little things you do on the side
yep
that make you a better comic because you
have more confidence when you go up on
stage
and I tell this all the time it's not
the little big things
it's huge doing stuff outside [ __ ] when
I made those it's the little thing is
unless you do anything and if you don't
know now it's true pens well you gotta
do them now are you gonna do them wait
and so if I was you I get the [ __ ]
we're doing yeah because you're either
gonna do it now or you're gonna have to
do it later yeah it's all part of the
process so yeah I'm telling you right
now to get the [ __ ] stepping well
likely when he came to uh Lee came out
to sack punchline where I recorded to do
an album and it was interesting because
I was sober until like the last show I
had a drink I didn't drink at all during
all those shows someone to be sharp and
then each night instead of like going
out I was listening to my sets and it
was just funny because I was like wow
this is what I did when I first started
and it's like easy to get into a habit
of like oh the shows are going great I
don't need to do this but but it made
the hugest difference like each set was
better I even added tags that weekend
that I hadn't even done that did so well
and it was just it's funny cuz Brody
when I did Brody's podcast like right
before he passed away and he said the
best lesson for me in comedy was active
listening like I stopped for a while and
then when I started my comedy got better
and I kept thinking about that and it
really makes the hugest difference it's
really weird what goes into being a
certain person whether you want to be a
psychiatrist whether you want to be a
good dentist it's not just gonna it's so
many different aspects and it's the same
with Tommy and everything you do around
that strengthens you
at some point you know you gonna improv
Olympic I don't believe in none of those
places but if you do six months there
and you mix it with get on stage every
night that helps it takes you somewhere
yeah we talked a lot about going off the
beaten path I have news for you guys
this is repetitive it's the same [ __ ]
every day
yeah you you gotta know you go off the
path at times and when you come out like
I've always stayed on the path with what
I had to do but mentally I've got off
the path from time to time and I've seen
it a couple months ago like meets
anaphor I shot the Netflix special I was
a little outside my game we read too
many edibles you know I was drawn in
some [ __ ] [ __ ] happy pill from
time to time yeah and I caught myself
and I was like you know what that was
then I gotta better myself so these are
little things I gotta do it's so weird
how these last three weeks in New York
that I spent were great weeks I had a
great time shooting seeing friends but
it also reminded me of something remind
me who I was
it's you know what's the Green Book I
know got me a woodland no I didn't see
it yet there's a line of that movie when
he goes at least I know who the [ __ ] I
am I'm from the Bronx
my mother was to the Bronx their mother
before them was from the Bronx their
mother before them was at the Bronx I
still gotta same restaurant every way
the most important thing in your life is
knowing who you are it's here at times
we forget we hang out with people and
you do different things with people so
you feel like you have to accommodate
and my sense and Mice and mice world you
know what happened I had a daughter but
a little fear of my life fear that I've
never had before like I didn't have this
fear before but now I'm not just playing
for me I'm playing on a team yeah you
know so it scared me a little bit going
back to New York reminded me who the
[ __ ] I was when I came back Sunday
swinging this weekend they were now over
there's people gonna be going down
because I don't have the time no more I
realized I was around people who were
around me when I was a thief and who
took [ __ ] for me for me being a thief
and told them to go [ __ ] themselves
before any of this stupid [ __ ] would
podcasting or movies or comedy they love
me for me yeah to be around that again I
realized one thing that what I have
around me today in LA is garbage
I have pure garbage around me in so many
different ways it made me an open my
eyes to a garbage I have around yeah
it's pathetic really you've become who
we are and it's this society it's not
the Society I'm from I still have
friends that hold on everything
sacred that they have everything like
one of my brother George Sammy I kept
one over enjoyed this little Langston I
am a couple times for sushi and then one
day asked him to tell me what was on a
Japanese thing and he said they said
that they couldn't read Japanese because
wrong Korean why am i a sushi that's
what I'm talking about
don't [ __ ] eat sushi with Koreans you
little things in life that make your
life a lot better
what do you so I knew I wasn't [ __ ] I
did not think that's where you're going
to the curry no I don't you know I'm
saying like I never got away from Who I
am I'm from North Bergen New Jersey I
never played golf and I never will play
golf and if you played golf you're a
[ __ ] follow unless you've been doing
it since the age of six yeah it's flat
plain and simple if your father was a
golfer and he took out there when you
were three but if you play golf to up
state your status and yeah you're
playing to make friends to be a [ __ ]
phony I don't want you around me I never
saw that growing up I saw that here mean
I saw a guy from Philly playing golf how
about I hit you in the head with that
[ __ ] Club
you're from Philly we don't [ __ ] go
okay I get it
you're cheeto you're right though I
[ __ ] came back here and I remembered
who I was everybody gotta wake up call
the last two days I had to say something
before and I had to say it because I'm
done I'm done that was around
the best I was around people who will
live and die for you they will put that
back against yours and say we got two
knives and we're going up against 20
[ __ ] Japs it's meaning you to the
[ __ ] enemy either they're sushi or
[ __ ] sushi it's I'm done I know I came
back and I realized one of the people I
got around me that's supposed to be
protecting me a garbage the people who
say to me oh we love it that garbage I'm
a right I just went back and saw the
people I was in Vietnam with Timmy
Halliwell came from New York Tommy club
says yeah what the dinner I looked into
her eyes and I saw ourselves again at 18
yeah call it discos how much money you
got twenty half gram a blow and I gotta
come back here to these [ __ ] people
who would just they just sit there
waiting for a bomb to go off it's hard
sitting here waiting for a bomb we're in
the same place I feel it's like it's
changed my outlook I fell off the beaten
path for a while I got a little sore you
get caught up sometimes too I got I have
I've kept my mouth shut
yeah and I haven't said nothing because
of my daughter yep
because this isn't a game it's our
future but like I told my wife yesterday
and guess what party's over
I started this with [ __ ] nothing and
I'll [ __ ] lose it all but I'm not
doing it no more cuz you want to be you
I'm not doing it on one 56 I'm too
[ __ ] old to play [ __ ] games and
when I [ __ ] tell you something you
gotta listen I don't give a [ __ ] what
you want to do what you do with this guy
or that guy that means nothing to me
it's my [ __ ] world at the end guess
who's here Ralphie May doesn't have a
gravestone at the end of the day that
[ __ ] died none of these agents
were or his friends or all these people
who went to the bet all those people I
got onstage at the bet nobody put a
[ __ ] except for those two twins Cory
and Chad who called me and said you know
Ralphie's been dead for a year and
doesn't have that open how the [ __ ] did
that happen his family this man we
didn't do it nobody not the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] wife with the videos what the
people donate that I told you not know
that [ __ ]
none that
so at the end you die alone and I've
known that from day one so take your
story
no you won't we all die alone we all
[ __ ] die alone watch the end of the
[ __ ] day take your [ __ ] stories
and take your [ __ ] and go get
something else you want to be my friend
this is what needs to be done and this
is how it needs to be done do you feel
like you have I feel the same as you and
I know we're similar and I know that's
why we are close and I that has been I
have had moments the last six months
we're like I love comedy I love
performing I love the art I love it
I [ __ ] hate the business I hate the
politics I hate that you have to flirt
with people for them to [ __ ] hire you
first [ __ ] I hate I mean it's different
being a girl for you it must be a
[ __ ] life it's it's it's why do you
think I treat you anyway I know I treat
you I know because I want me to be
different than anybody else you are a
wife you are I want you to know that you
have truth here yeah don't get me wrong
you've been though well [ __ ] you the end
up with you you have truth I won't blow
smoke up your ass yeah I know no I'm
fine but I used to this is where I've
changed and this is where it's been a
struggle lately because set wise
comedy-wise
I'm really happy like things are great
like I perform I feel great people I'm
the feedback is great everything's going
well I'm writing I'm excited about [ __ ]
but it's all the I just I don't want to
jump through the hoop I used to be the
person that would go to the party and
network with everyone talk to everyone
flirt with everyone know everyone I'm
exhaust I can't do both anymore because
well you know what I mean like we meet
everybody talk to everybody
nobody at me but that's what I'm saying
you meet somebody there pain the bravest
expression I ever heard was if they were
here they wouldn't be anybody anyway
from a great manager I forget what the
guys name what the no it's no bad I've
had people see me in and like my agent
my agent saw me at the improv like it's
happened to me before
how were you on stage yeah okay then
that's not Network oh yeah you're saying
go to a party oh I agree with that yes I
agree with that for me why stay after
oh that never will happen no that never
my god it's such a pleasure give me a
call I'd love to call you next week
while there's not your coke that's on
there gonna call you and then they wake
up the next morning they go you know
what why would I hire them they suck
coke also no no business have you do my
coke last night now you want higher
because I do coke be there you are I
know it's one foot bump would be last
night doing [ __ ] rayless actually
that's true I've left parties I
literally was at I think it was
Chappelle's birthday party or something
at the nice guy one night and all the
[ __ ] Gersh was there so I left
because that's my agency I'm like I'm
not getting tanked and [ __ ] up in
front of everybody that gets well it was
Christmas or something
the point is though but now I have okay
well anybody they wouldn't be here
anyway that's the word yeah anybody
that's not true they wouldn't be always
true but they're not gonna give you work
when they're partying that's what is the
truth and you know what I've seen it for
22 years I was here two years and he
said that ma you know said that he'll
Chris Cornell's old father-in-law
oh okay he used to be married to
whatever her name was her father was one
of the biggest managers in this town
he's got a communist when he was old and
one night he said that and my whole
demeanor changed because I believe
there's no networking you want to
network your network onstage you're a
common yeah nothing happens party
I agree oh now you're dead yeah yes we
used to say if there were anybody
wouldn't be here that's true but also
it's it just a matter of energy I mean
you know cuz every time you call me
lately
I actually feel guilty when I talk to
you because you're always like so what
else is going on I'm like really nothing
cuz I'm not doing anything anyway I
never go out but it's also part you
always before well no I I don't mean
nothing like I went to this place the
other night and this [ __ ] idiot did
22 minutes ahead of me in any jerked off
on stage yeah Alicia telling me you went
out I always go up I always go up I
guess I'm always working but I just mean
like I feel like I'm at
point where I feel like the but maybe
I'm wrong but I feel like the better you
get at stand-up and performing the more
energy I use so much more energy than I
used to I'm like I don't have the energy
to be as social as I used to be and be
good at my job I have to pick now it
didn't used to be that way maybe it's
just getting old I don't know but now I
just do nothing man I mean I don't do
nothing I work but I'd rather be home
cutting a podcast or listening to my
audio or like even catching up on a show
I've never seen that everyone's doing
jokes about like I'd rather that also
going home
change me this past year like what we
were talking about on the phone like you
were saying how good it was to be home
this was the first year I've been to
Ohio three or four times this year my
mom has lupus so she's alright but I
just like I'm conscious of the fact that
you know she won't be around forever my
nephews are growing up they hardly ever
see me and I used to go home to Ohio and
be bored after a day and now I'm never
bored there because it's just it's
peaceful and nobody's asking me [ __ ]
about my career and nobody's asking me
questions about celebrity it's just it's
like they don't they really don't care
they don't know anything about this
world and it's just I feel like I can
tune out there and I feel like I went
through a phase in Hollywood that a lot
of people go through where I moved here
things started to pop a little I got in
with this crowd of like it's exciting at
first you're like oh it's celebrities
there's drugs there's all this oh my god
this guy is hitting on me this is crazy
and then after a while that's just feels
so empty so empty and then this this is
the first year every time I've gone home
I don't want to come back but I want to
work but I get like sad to come back to
where it's like it just feels fake and I
never wanted to be that person that
thinks la is fake I don't want to be
jaded it's so sometimes enjoyable say
things to me and it doesn't happen right
away but I like when it happened like
we're talking about the guy with the
onion but then the like the past couple
weeks I've been here by like three or
four people who pull me aside like and
the thing is for me it's like I didn't
really have a ton of friends growing up
so now when people are trying to be
super friendly with me it's like what
yeah I don't really believe it and then
they like yeah like I had someone give
me a script and I hate I even told them
I was like there's no way he's gonna do
it like I tried yeah like there's no
like there's no way yeah and he's like
one I'm really persistent I'm like okay
and I'm like oh so that's why you wanted
I'm like you don't really to be
sometimes it makes me like shy even
makes a person feel yeah and I totally
this would happen yeah of course I want
to say before it happens you're gonna
feel bad you don't mean over the years
how many people would hit me after it
first starts oh we love you we were your
college and then they want something
from someone I want your oh yeah okay I
get that on the road people come up to
me and they talk to me for a while and
then it goes okay man how does Joey book
his podcast like people do that to me
it's it's they don't understand that
we've seen it already
yeah like we'll prepare like I told you
yesterday I would never could you
imagine me calling you going yo I met
this dude at the hotdog stand at the
mall he wants to do your podcast like
you would [ __ ] hang up on me it is
ridiculous it is ridiculous what you get
and it's it's getting it's getting it's
not getting annoying lag of a ting it's
getting sad that what people will think
it's sad it's also add what people think
they could accomplish by cutting corners
and you try to help him the best was the
one you know I was gone and I I wanted
to give social media a break yeah I
noticed you could just look at social
media so much before you going off I
want to shoot myself it's true and then
Twitter's doesn't bother me it's
Facebook where people are just really
stuck I don't even go through that [ __ ]
anymore I don't look at it so I come
back to a hundred messages yeah I'm
going through them some of me put a
thumb some of them you write back and I
got the one from truckin you know
Milwaukee that they paid it was a great
show and then pictures of me and them
and and then [ __ ] a whole article on
why we didn't party afterward I'll hang
out that that's what they came to they
were upset that they paid 27:58 go whoa
I always try to put a dynamite comic in
front of me
yeah I try to keep my ticket prices low
I go you were looking for a friend
2750 you weren't looking to see a show I
go get a dog
join the [ __ ] Lonely Hearts Club
because I provide a show it's also a
meal you're riding a [ __ ] you're not
going back to the hotel room with me I
just did two shows I really am NOT the
mood to talk it's exhausting but people
don't understand and I get it yeah you
want to say hello and give him a hug
take a picture but don't ask me about
World War three and what I think about
the Joe Rogan controversy we've been
saved of 2000 I know that's the last
thing I want to hear on my mind I know I
can't even think I've just been scraping
for material also though it for two
hours scraping the bottom of my mind
yeah temples you're going deep for your
material and now you want to ask me a
question about oh we there's a winter Oh
No
Clinton I have no [ __ ] idea they
don't realize that they're one person
and then there's 300 more gravity on the
line I would learn to keep your mouth
shut
put your hand down to say hello that's
it before you gonna say something wrong
don't say nothing I know there's what
you're gonna say is wrong anyway just
put your hand down and say it's a
pleasure to meet you - pleasure to meet
you what's your name
ya always ask people what their name is
I wanna know what their name is and then
they tell you and then you take a
picture with them and that's it I don't
have time for a short story there's 60
people on the line yeah yeah it's hard I
want to do this to them the thing is
they would never do that could you
imagine someone messaging like Eddie Van
Halen or like and going hey after the
show why don't we party like they would
never do it - like a musician or like an
actor in a Broadway show I don't know
why because because we come out and meet
people which is a generous thing to do
really like no performer I don't sell
merch you don't sell more than somebody
you don't agree about yeah for that
particular reason I don't so I don't you
to say hello and not feel like you have
to give me $25 for a [ __ ] t-shirt
same I don't want I don't want and I
don't sell it because I don't want to be
obligated to come out yeah you
tell me you like the podcast is well you
came you like a subject matter if I want
to sell you something I'm not on your
door Yeah right sorry encyclopedias the
stakes door the door whatever there's
just so many aspects of it that people
really go understand I'm not there to
sell you a piece I'm happy I got you for
the 20 cents how I feel but you're a
lapi that you got a babysitter you're
not a nickel and dime er you're not
someone that seems ever to me that
you're in it for I mean making money is
great but you're not money driven you
know why that it's not gonna get you
what you want that's how I am which is
happiness yeah all we're searching for
us to wake up with a smile on your face
and not be like the rest of [ __ ] America
that's depressed or upset about the
political climate sure the Koreans are
gonna strike this you can't yeah well
also how lucky we are like that [ __ ] for
40 years of my life
I hate [ __ ] my mother died when I was 16
yeah and if I don't know how many years
after that I'm I did it on purpose
because of my love for Carly
I kept a low nut I didn't drive a
Cadillac I didn't try to prove to people
I was on my way and then it was such a
low nut that I kind of enjoyed it that's
how I am that's why I have a Hyundai you
know I come from a society where there's
no flash
yeah there's no flash for various
reasons for the most viruses I don't
want to make somebody feel bad I'm not
that person but I'm around I love Jews
too much I got a BMW do you understand
me yes I do no I mean you don't I
couldn't see what I am W I wouldn't get
a BM don't care how much money they give
me I belong in a Subaru or war truck
yeah that's who I am
yes well always be a blue-collar when
there are a million dollars of that
ain't gonna make you happy well that's
how I am oh honey when you're 21 you
think I can't wait to have a Testarossa
and have [ __ ] on your arm and do
drugs every day and let me tell you some
and ain't no [ __ ] bargain there's a
price to pay because what's the cocaine
the money again all those things go with
it and happiness always
sticks or you're thriving so in this
life is to laugh laugh at yourself you
know when I fought on a plane you know
you know and I still find the way to
laugh when I used to I used to have to
drop my daughter off when she was six
you know Jacqueline my first daughter I
would cry when I drop her off so guess
what I did
I forced myself to do comedy after I
dropped her off as an exercise because I
want to be able to do comedy if my
[ __ ] mother died that morning well
you've done it we've done it we've done
yeah Vegas I want to be able to do Tommy
I just buried my mother yep I still
gotta be able tired but you have to
Train you have to end this pain and this
is that that's pause that was fair
enough that was really [ __ ] hard
stand up yeah you know yeah you have to
train yourself onto all these conditions
you know what this time is if you really
dive into stand-up you gonna have to
sleep on some of these guys for six
months at one point your life easily
easily yeah if you really won't be
homeless Lea you're gonna be homeless
get ready you have to be prepared to go
I remember when Ralphie May was homeless
and joy Medina took them in dude stand
up people will I used to drive to San
Diego I would spend I didn't even
actually I didn't even have a car at the
time I would take a train to San Diego
it was like thirty dollars each way or
something stay in a hotel and only get
paid $20 for the set like I was losing
money to do spots just because you want
the spots that's it
but I feel like it's like building any
business you invest in the business you
have to do a corporation yeah you're
just a CEO of a corporation and you know
that you stock his love the thing is
that stock is low right yeah the thing
is I've been working on and you helped
me with this because one day I was
talking to you and I was bummed because
there was some things I wasn't getting
and I was frustrated and you said focus
on the things you do have not the things
you don't have and I've really trained
my mind like it's amazing that you can't
train your mind
to focus on the positive you can do it
it's just it's an exercise I've been
writing down this is so [ __ ] cheesy
people are gonna be like what happened
to you okay but I've been writing down
like ten things every day that I'm
thankful for and sometimes when I'm sad
I'll start doing that and it'll really
fix it because the fact is we are so
[ __ ] lucky you're alive
you don't have cancer you're not gonna
chemotherapy treatment look at what
we're doing I was in your pocket to go
to Subway I can afford I get a veggie
and cheese sandwich yeah you breathe it
I'm yeah every morning I wake up when I
was 21 I didn't have that perspective
yeah
when I was 21 I'm broke I'm a loser and
I'm miserable but it was robbed around
revolved around money money wasn't
making so much better yeah I got the 40
I was like Jesus Christ I'm [ __ ]
estatic I'm at The Comedy Store in it I
may have eight thousand twenty two cents
in mine that's it yeah but I'm a static
there's a line in narcos Mexico that
Darko's Mexico it's about Kiki Camarena
and at the end you know if you haven't
seen not close to Mexico you're not
gonna watch and I don't give a [ __ ] if I
spoil your thing
well Game of Thrones I don't give a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] your brother [ __ ] you and games
you [ __ ] mouth Game of Thrones will
you stop go back to the scene when he's
in when he thinks he looks onto the
ocean and he remembers his interview
with Kiki Camarena and he lights a
cigarette new yours I do these because
well his key camera in a sitting there
with his eye out of his [ __ ] head
with drill bits getting put through his
leg and this guy walks in and he takes
the guys out and he's telling them why
he's doing this
yeah it was Tommy you wanna go home guys
tell him I have kids please send me home
and this guy just starts talking Diego
Luna was a phenomenal act and he goes
like goes why the singer he was I used
these because they reduce stress but if
you know what's crazy that when I was
broke I slept like a baby and now that I
have money I can't sleep at night that
is
[ __ ] my head that's so real I was broken
I had nothing I slept like a baby it's
so real now I sleep two three hours a
night and you think about that sentence
and it's what I'm telling you people we
focus on the wrong things
money is nothing and money is garbage
money will come and go it's a worse
addiction than cocaine once you take
money out of the picture and you go wow
I'm doing this because I love it that's
genuinely love this I could get up every
morning and do this for free whether
it's taking it in the ass or [ __ ]
building fireplaces or lighting Jews on
fire don't do this but I'm just making a
point is I won't get a BMW but this is
what you do he might he probably has no
then until you really fall in love with
that there it's a journey and look at
the sky and go I'm living in a hovel
that's it I got rats I'm sharing the
sandwich or the red I've done that but
boy literally I love what I do and all
of a sudden a month after that God will
unload a suitcase on you of dollar bills
it's true think you're a [ __ ]
stripper when you think you don't need
it it shows it shows up dude when I
moved to LA when I was a kid I love
water
like I'm a huge pool I swam I was on the
swim team growing up my grandma had a
pool my dad lived at a lake I was in
water like every day in my life and I
always wanted to live by the ocean that
was like my dream nothing else but live
by the ocean and be on TV that's all I
wanted when I was a kid I didn't care
how happened and when I moved to LA I
lived for a little while in like New
York like Slauson area like by the
airport and then I found this studio
apartment it was such a [ __ ] in
Venice Beach I mean it was a total crack
then but it was two blocks off of Venice
like right where the V is in Venice
where like all the homeless dudes hang
out and [ __ ] I run in this place at the
time I was married so my husband was
moving out
here to live with me in this little
studio the two of us there were homeless
guys literally peeing on my window or on
the ground floor but every day I would
walk across the street to the beach was
right across the street and I was just
like this is the [ __ ] dream like I
was so I mean I had the biggest [ __ ]
eating grin on my face the whole time I
lived there cuz it was the beach I did
call the police three or four times or
dudes like jerking off outside the
window like [ __ ] that like never there
was a guy who used to swim in my pool
naked when I would come out but none of
it mattered because I could walk to
ocean and I feel like every step of the
business for me has been like that like
everything like TV like if I died
tomorrow I could say I did everything
when I was a kid I wanted to do I got to
do a comedy set on Showtime
I had a TV show and I lived at the beach
I could die tomorrow and I'm like I did
it all and so the rest I feel like is
icing so I think that that's why for me
like the gratitude thing is getting
easier to be grateful for what I have
because if I just think back about what
I wanted versus what I got and then on
top of that I got all those things
without losing my character my soul I
didn't have to [ __ ] I never [ __ ]
anybody for anything I got to do it the
right way it just feels so much better
and I'm not rich and I'm not famous like
I don't want to really be that famous I
want to be able to say whatever I want I
don't want to be so famous and if I
tweet something I'm in trouble you want
to be famous too late I know not to the
birds I know more than when somebody
calls me a [ __ ] celebrity I'm a dirty
Club you're a regular dude that's that's
it that's r-rated that you don't want I
love that if you don't want to be there
I'd rather you not come don't come to
impress your boyfriend you got I don't
want none of those type of audiences
yeah you know it was so funny how is in
New York and people were hit me up hey
man how come you don't come to the
Comedy Cellar to do with this you know
why because I just want to be left to
[ __ ] alone yeah I wanted danger feels 22
people a night
people last Monday [ __ ] tremendous
small stage
I knew rodney was on that stage I knew
Bill Hicks was on that score yelling I
knew dices on that stage yeah I knew
[ __ ] Kennison was on that stage so
it's just like being at the Comedy Store
but it's not the hot Club people were
like freaking like you should do the
comments on how you go tell your mother
to go do to calm yourself
I'll be at [ __ ] Dangerfield with
the Eastside [ __ ] relax
where I belong to be you understand
those are the best though those are the
best that's why I love playing like far
gigs and [ __ ] that's what I like
rowdy bar crowd that's my favorite the
most important thing in this whole
[ __ ] game is knowing who the [ __ ] you
are and what your limitations are on
what you can't do and be honest about I
can't do that okay I will do that okay I
won't do that okay once you start
compromising that you're gonna paint in
your [ __ ] salt and that's what's been
going on with me lately right
the last couple years I just been I
wouldn't have done half the things I did
yeah looking back at them there's a
couple things I was not done at all but
it happened to get you to this place
where you knew that I'd noticed yeah I
think it all like I could tell you're in
trouble I can tell and when I come back
from next week you're really in trouble
but I really missed you like for real
like I miss you you being gone from LA
that call I made you this morning I
couldn't make that call to a lot of
people I was so good my god to you
because I was somewhere you were
somewhere and I sent you the most
depressing text of all time like I said
Joe via text that literally I was like
on a plane I was so depressed I know you
don't tell I just I had some [ __ ] go
down that was like I felt kind of
invaded like I had like I got trolled a
little bit but it was personal and I was
just depressed man I was in Ohio and I
did a college it was great the gig went
great but it's weird when you're in your
I was in my home state but not close
enough to see my family and I was by
myself on the road and I just kind of
was going through it and I was also
feeling a lot of just what it's weird
that you were feeling so much I was
feeling just about feeling a little like
I'm not fitting in as much as I used to
out here I don't
like I have as many friends as I used to
out here cuz I'm just realizing who's
really friends and who isn't and I was
just feeling lonely and I sent Joey this
[ __ ] text on the plane that was just
like I'm sorry having talked too much
last couple weeks I've been kind of
depressed and when I talked to Joey like
you're like Fitz you're so family to me
like I never want to like let you down
like I want to make you proud all the
time so I didn't want to call you
because I knew you were doing the movie
and like I'm so happy for you and I
didn't want to like bring you down but
then when you called me today and you
were kind of like I've been going
through [ __ ] it made me feel like so
good that you called me about it because
I just I don't know I felt it made me
feel happy that you could call me about
that it's not all in my neighborhood
just walking in I was like what am i
doing my [ __ ] life why these people
around me I would not be sick or dead
with these people please and the people
that I have [ __ ] with me would be
missing in the year they've been walking
around like [ __ ] Joey punch me in the
[ __ ] mouth so hard and I'm tolerating
this [ __ ] for 10 years I've tolerated
this the specialist is my daughter was
born I've tolerated this behavior from
people that at the end of the day I
wouldn't piss on them if they were on
fire I will miss another day one fire
yeah I grew up with people that had my
back when there was nothing there when I
was just a [ __ ] pure street thief I
gave him a piece of my action I always
took care of her everybody always got a
little taste yeah why am I putting up
with these people around me that don't
wanna have my best interests in their
heart and in their minds they're just
it's hard it's a very hard thing you
know and they're everywhere there's an
element of that in every job that people
there's always probably people in every
business that it's like it's hard when
you have to feel like you have to be a
little fake to get to a point you want
in your career and it's it I feel like
it just to order you get it's like you
don't want to [ __ ] fake [ __ ] I think
that I think there is there's like one
or two people in an office usually but
the problem in five in LA there's some
good people in LA
I think you're right it's like if you
move here singing you're gonna be the
next even the best director like there's
some people like if you think you're
that special Oh nine times out of 10
you're gonna be kind of a stinky person
well I even being just like for instance
like there are guys booking [ __ ] TV
shows clubs whatever that have been
really shitty to me in the past you know
cuz I didn't want to [ __ ] them and then
I had to be around these people
oh that cool how bad do you feel for
them now when they see you and they
can't make eye contact with you I don't
feel bad for that guys that won't talk
to you cuz you didn't [ __ ] up when they
booked rooms and they won't put you in
their rooms
yeah it's so it sucks it's such it's
sucks but anytime I go to him I always
tell people that like when I go to
Pittsburgh or whatever all these sounds
I know you I'm no idea how happy I am to
be time you walk at the airport there's
no Jessie silhouettes
there's no Harvey Weinstein there's none
of his victims laying around trying a
molester them there's no never Neverland
there's no [ __ ] you know it's very
people don't understand when I go to
Milwaukee in Michigan only all [ __ ]
Texas you think this would exist in
Texas
Harvey Weinstein woulda lasted in the
POW he got shot for sure only exists in
how you pull that that stunt in Chicago
justice Millette will never be there
some black people in Chicago got a black
to the bone that they really know what
the struggle is for this [ __ ]
half-breed [ __ ] Thrun whatever the
[ __ ] he is yeah to do what he did he
doesn't deserve the love not an American
community but this would only happen
here you don't see a black guy tell him
that to Nigerian has jumped him in New
York City knows you're really black
you're black
yeah you're black you wouldn't even use
that stunt but right in the letter to
him so you think of all the things it's
a great way no I don't that's crazy
I do not ain't Jesse smaller
I feel bad for Jesse Smollett because
he's another victim of this douchebag
garbage can [ __ ] changed you but you
had to pick man you can if that's if he
wasn't that guy though on some level I
mean I've regretted things like the
whole the whole thing in this business
is every day almost there's a choice you
can make to stick to what you believe or
to sell sell out every day and like
there's been times that I've done things
that I believed in the moment and then
later I was like man I wish I hadn't
done that said that talked about that
maybe I feel different now
maybe I should let some time go but ever
since I started the one thing I believed
in for me was my talent and so like I
always turned down all the shortcuts
that I knew would [ __ ] with my head like
I couldn't and you know like even when I
dated comics like like I dated Bobby and
like he was like you can work with me
and I was like I don't want to because I
don't want people to think that's why
this is happening
guys I mean he's great he's great he's a
little weirdo but he's great he's still
got a good I still love it and you know
he's funny as [ __ ] man boy is so goddamn
funny and he does have a good heart and
you know what I'll say about Bobby Bobby
is one person that when we were first
hanging out I remember people talking so
much [ __ ] like what is she doing with
Bob like really she's only with Bobby
because XYZ he's rich he's payment
whatever the truth is Bobby made me feel
so special
Bobby give a million compliment and he
makes you feel like you would always be
like you're gonna be such a big star
you're so brilliant you got and like
that's really all it takes for women if
you give us a lot of compliments and you
make us feel good about ourselves
we're staying because that's what
everybody wants to feel loved and
Bobby's amazing at that that's always
the kind of guys that I'm attracted to
are guys that like have a childlike
nature and make me feel really special I
mean that's what everybody wants right
at the end of the day women at least I
don't know that what did you see Dee
come at Oh I'm editing it right now
I'm really happy with it I'm excited
about the whole in Sacramento
turned out great let me help you
recorded that room was so dope punchline
that room is amazing [ __ ] and the San
Francisco punchline I haven't done that
one oh that's God's gift that's 180 you
know it's funny about the sack punchline
is they don't tell you the stage there
there's a like a scrim like there's like
what does it look like a sheet it looks
like a brick wall is an artwork or
something on the back but they didn't
they don't tell you it's not a hard wall
you know most the time you can lean on
it put your leg over it [ __ ] leaned
on it and I felt like I was gonna fall
through the window it's like four feet
away or something from the window yeah
with fluffy I opened up for fluffy ten
years ago when I went through that
window you did not know I almost did
yeah I did too I'm recording and I
literally I leaned out I'm like so much
to tell the comic this is not a wall it
looks like a wall it's a 4-foot gap yeah
and you're on the second floor you're
dead if you follow charm like [ __ ] so
not to like ring-a-ding-ding and you
just keep going you'll land on top of
the [ __ ] BMW escape if I was you I
probably would have gone out the window
but luckily I bounced back God there's
another place too but I put my leg up
one night to rest on the wall yeah and I
went back like a [ __ ] mummy oh yeah
have you ever eaten [ __ ] like falling
down getting on I saw a video of some of
the other night Oh Chelsea Skidmore who
you had on here she posed some video her
going up on stage of the conversation
just completely tripped and like fell
flat on her iPhone be original you did
yeah because it's three steps so yeah
gonna try to [ __ ] make them really
fast yeah and you get that [ __ ] 12
inch that 13 inch foot I got got caught
on one of those things and I went down
on my knees people laugh is the bastard
who always gives a [ __ ] it's funny
because now you have some to work with
doesn't matter it's brilliant because
you only fall after you wrote for one
week straight you got 30 minutes and you
have memorized and now you fall but you
have to say something about the fall
talk about how your feet are doing how
your clumsy and your mother always found
you're drunk you quit drinking Yeah
right
I haven't fallen I'm trying to think if
I fall I've tripped down stairs coming
off in fact oh I ate [ __ ] in the belly
room before coming from you know they
have that little like upper part where
you can watch from then you have to come
down those two three stairs well for the
longest time they weren't taped or
anything you couldn't see the stairs
really and it was pitch black I fell
down those stairs like three times
coming down like all the time I would
fall not drunk or anything just fall now
you know they changed it what do you
looking for for the future what are you
thinking I'm doing honestly there's a
show right now that I'm not even I was I
started out pitching this show that I
really want to do and then I just
decided to get funding for it and do it
I don't know if I should say what it is
though but it's such a fun you know I
came up with an idea that is just
something that I'm like if I could do
anything if I had like a hundred grand
and I could do anything I wanted what
would I do and then I try to develop a
funny concept out of it and it's great
and I have people interested in
sponsoring it and so I want to make that
but my goal is to keep making [ __ ] on my
own like put my [ __ ] if no one wants to
buy a special put it on you just cancel
something and I saw that these people
put it up to II cancelled this show yeah
boozie boozie Phillips or something oh
yeah Oh busy Phillips she was kind of
like doing the Chelsea Handler type show
or something like that she does unless
we get picked up somewhere else and do
it yourself do so that's my thing now
I'm like what even with a special you
know like [ __ ] it I can shoot a special
anywhere and put it I would clip it up
and put it on YouTube those clips go
viral people come to your shows it's it
really a special to go anywhere they'll
find it if you advertise it correctly
understand yeah to be honest it might do
more on YouTube yeah well I get a lot of
people at my shows that I mean I don't
love all my clips on this site but you
know the Laugh Factory puts up clips
everyone somehow if you approve them so
I always approve the ones that are kind
of like something I wrote that's for
that day and I'm probably not gonna use
it again then I give it to them and I
get people to come out and they're like
oh we love you on the LAV factories you
can watch
yeah you really don't that's why you
need to that's it I was around I had a
video on Will Ferrell's three years ago
and funnier guy and I had hits and
nobody would I think they picked up a
joint karate or something like that yeah
it's weird what different forms people
watch it on you never listen we live in
a in a cyber world now is that what you
call a computer well cyber world that's
yeah it's digital age it's unlimited I
run into people all the time that [ __ ]
cuz they don't have this special that
special I'm like well get a [ __ ]
camera go to a comedy club and do 15
minutes you know the truth Joey though
too is like I know everybody's like I
know you're always like a man with a
plan X Y Z I know it's important but
what's really helped me is to just keep
working every day that's it and be happy
and I don't give myself because I used
to put a lot of pressure on myself to
have you know there's a list of things I
have to do in this amount of time and it
was giving me anxiety and you know what
I think about now like when I think
about what I want to do I think I want
to keep moving ahead everything is going
well everything I want to make I'm
working on but I want to go [ __ ]
camping like I want to go fishing like I
want to go hang out in national park
like I'm starting to think about stuff
that I miss doing that I mean I need you
know I spoke to Harry when I got here
and we were howling in the car really
Alan he's a new man because because he
takes these breaks and he gets off wine
and is out of here yep he saw what the
stress was of having a show yeah
everybody wants your show until they get
one and then you don't know what it is
to have why argue with people fight with
people over lines they don't want this
they don't want that they don't want
this I bumped into somebody in New York
who sold was showing English you know
what I'm grateful I didn't pick up hey
he shot a pilot and everything yeah it's
just those eight months were
mind-boggling you don't have taken you
have to have a tough skin for that and
either you could do it or you can't I am
very surprised like I said I thought
before I sweat agree this soprano will
I was very close to pull it out of the
movie
no way fears because I just I'm quietly
the mood to work on this set yeah it's a
different it's sort of a different
animal for me I've done it for a long
time and it I just don't like that time
anymore well cuz you're so used to also
being your own boss now you're on your
own schedule you make your own your to
go back weird like I tell people all the
time you got a TV show if it don't shoot
at CBS Radford you're not gonna see me
there but the thing is now that if you
have an audience it's like my idea that
I want to do it's like once you build an
audience and you can get people to
sponsor your [ __ ] and if you're not
worried I'm not worried about making
millions I'm worried about paying my
bills I can pay my bills and be happy so
why do I need to sell this [ __ ] to MVC
or [ __ ] Netflix but just make it get
sponsors put it up you can make money
like I'm so I feel very fortunate and it
took a long time but now I have enough
people following me to get people to
sponsor stuff I want to do so there's no
reason that I need to stress about I
haven't sold a script I don't have a
sitcom I don't know who cares I'm happy
I'm so happy like I feel the happiest
and that's why - like with would like
not dating and stuff it's just I think
I've realized for me that like the last
drama I keep in my life the more fresh
air the more I get outside warm around
people I love I'm just happy and that's
all that matters could die tomorrow
Brody died changed me too because you
know I remember doing his podcast before
he passed and him talking about the like
trolling was getting to him like people
bullying him online
not bullying but like making fun of him
or whatever and it would bother him and
I remember just thinking to myself like
everyone loves Brody so much but he
sometimes didn't feel it and I just
don't it's not worth it it's not worth
it to put yourself in a positive I don't
want to put myself in a position where I
have eight billions in we doing rows
about yeah no I don't like it either
yeah me neither I like to be people on
the internet now I saw a remark about
three days ago that was the most
backhanded
stupid remark I ever saw in my life but
I look at him now I'm not gonna be
Johnny Christian to say I pray for them
I don't give a [ __ ] okay the
treeschoolers you see razor scooter on
Sunset sock so it's people go get hit by
a truck you don't wish that what you you
look at them ago I wonder where they're
coming from
I wonder what cuz they hate themselves
they have to write that yeah you know I
wonder what that's it
you know it's just you have to wonder
what they're going through to be in that
position to put themselves in that
position what could happen I mean yeah
that's where you go you only dates
coming up you dirty [ __ ] yes I do for a
second I thought you meant guys I was
like wait I'm no I know what you're
talking about i know domme just kidding
wait what's today Oh actually Thursday
night at Roy I'm at Bray Improv I'm
headlining improv you got Lee's comment
Jack juniors doing it and then uh I have
a whole actually have a whole bunch of
dates coming up just go to my website
yeah okay calm or Kate Q funny I mean
I'm sorry that you were going through
what you were going through after we go
okay I'm glad we got to talk what was
going on this morning I was a little
cookie at one point today but cuz I had
a meeting at 12:45 okay I know your
business oh uh no I took care of that I
really wanted to work out today I
probably haven't been to jujitsu in a
[ __ ] month
ah and they drop this on me this morning
so I ran around all morning a little bit
I got a little bit of writing done than
that you need to get to jujitsu cuz
that's like your so you love it so much
that's such a big box Sunday and I went
lifting yes Lee don't stop I know you
want kickboxer yeah well no were there
Sunday
oh no here at Brett's oh you did I got
off the plane Saturday went Sundays open
Matt you going there right the bicycle
do jumping jacks oh damn do kettlebell
you do whatever you want there Sunday
today good for you look at you yeah no
wonder you look so [ __ ] sleepy
they got open man on Sunday so I want to
punch bags I have pink boxing gloves I
use them at the gym that's great
I just ruin the whole thing it's like
wait a roué
don't forget you little dirty bastards
June 7th I'm at the Fillmore in Harris
in New Orleans [ __ ] and June 8th I'm
at the Tabernacle Theatre thing under
going fast on that one
so you better not [ __ ] around and then
six twenty eight and six twenty nine I'm
coming back with me and Kate just
destroyed on four twenty a year and a
half ago when the guy had the [ __ ]
stroke the Columbus [ __ ] funny bone
one of my favorites I go see my girl
crew hope and do a little Muay Thai
while I'm there and that's it and that's
that I want to thank Kate Quigley for
coming on the show this week I'm making
me laugh and making me smile right here
brightening my day and hopefully
brightening your [ __ ] day also
but before we go we need to talk okay
you're two weeks away from Memorial Day
weekend everybody's hot to trot you want
to bust out the white shorts you got new
shoes you got a new car but you haven't
done nothing about that ugly pogo stick
you got between your legs your ball
still smell like that and you wonder why
your last three girlfriends left you
maybe it's time to [ __ ] and trim around
the bushes and clean up down there a
little bit okay
that's where manscape calm comes in
manscape they got precision tools for
the Family Jewels manscape has designed
the electric razor
they breathe design the electric razor
sorry about that their invention is the
lawnmower think about it a handheld
razor with skin-safe technology so you
don't snick Nick or snag the nutsack or
the [ __ ] pogo stick of life gotta go
easy on what the Lord gave you guys this
bad boy will leave your nice clean
smooth and pain free and most important
anxiety freak just listen I love my wife
but I don't trust her with the razor
around my dick I gotta look up in the
sky make believe I don't have anxiety I
gotta take one of those anxiety pills
manscape we'll get your bean bag looking
as smooth as a [ __ ] that gets Easter
all year round when you got manscape I'm
gonna let you in on a little secret if
you trim the hedges the [ __ ] pogo
stick looks a lot bigger so what are you
waiting for trim up that [ __ ] stick
of the dead
everybody wants a black dick
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a way to
get a black dick shave the hair off and
the dick looks bigger and you can tell
your friends you got a black dick but it
starts at manscape dot-com [ __ ]
you get everything you need to make your
ball shine and keep your dick looking
[ __ ] like [ __ ] Richard Gere in
Pretty Woman you know I'm saying if my
dick could look like Richard Gere in
Pretty Woman I wouldn't even talk to
half of you [ __ ] savages I put a
little tuxedo on him and bring him to
parties hold his head is if this is the
first time you did sit in manscaping
they got a deal for you all right thing
at the perfect package that comes with a
lawnmower and the safety razor plus the
crop preserver which is a
specially-designed formulated deodorant
so your balls don't stink and they have
the Reviver spritz that tones and
refreshes your nutsack ooh and it keeps
them cool it's like sticking an
acupuncture needle in your nutsack and
it does a music and they got a nice
little ball white package they got
everything listen manscape calm is the
way to go for the sum if your dick was
like a soup if your dick look like it's
been hit by a car
manscape is the way for you and right
now the church or what's happened now
the family gets 20% off your first order
when you use promo code church at
manscape calm again promo code church at
manscape calm now if you order the
perfect package Dolf they'll throw in a
free travel bag when you use promo code
church who takes care you like me no
body so it's manscape calm use promo
code shirts and get 20% off your first
order and keep your balls looking tight
okay even I'm 56 but my balls got a
certain tightness tool that's what shut
the [ __ ] up it started before I make you
sniff one you saying you want to talk
this no they smell like 35 year old
cheese if you got a company you're
trying to put things together you're
looking for the best employees out there
I got the answer for you the zip
recruiter that's right zip recruiter
makes hiring
a piece of cake just hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
could go we're hiring a simple fast and
smart that place where growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates it's called zip recruiter
dot-com / Church hiring is hard enough
multiple job sites stacks a resumes
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy and it saves you time
and money when you get it done with zip
recruiter com
Joey why is zip recruiting the best why
let me tell you I'll tell you why they
send your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans through
thousands of resumes to find the right
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruit
analyzes each one and they spotlight the
top candidates so you never miss a great
match I don't care if you got three
employees or 200 employees if you're
looking for employees you gotta go with
zip recruit comm and right now the
church family you got a business there's
the way to go hook you up for free did
you hear that fre fre e free go to zip
recruiter comm slash church again that's
zip recruiter comm slash Church the
smartest way to hire go to zip recruiter
and don't forget Sunday is Mother's Day
today is [ __ ] Wednesday
you got Thursday Friday Saturday when
the chance is you're gonna go to
Marshalls and get her purse one of the
chances you're gonna go to [ __ ]
Target and get us some [ __ ] whatever
you're not gonna do these things this is
the way to go
proflowers.com why because it's coming
up May 12th
don't forget and where would you be
without your mom you'd be in a toilet
somewhere swimming around that's where
you'd be getting eaten by fishes throw
flowers is here to help you show
appreciation to your mom this year my
wife she's gonna get 20 dozen of these
why because she's the goods that's why
nice colors it comes in we got roses you
get yellow roses you get red roses I
don't know what other car they got roses
and that's all you need to make
somebody's day because at the end you
can't be a good Christian unless just
makes
somebody's day and do it with ProFlowers
they let you choose from a variety of
bouquets and visors that suit every mom
style all you got to do is pick the
delivery date that's it
then ProFlowers carefully packages your
flowers and delivers them fresh from the
farm express delivery means her flowers
stay fresh
you make mom happy and who's bad above
all there's nobody better than make
happen in your mom so right now got a
dozen assorted roses for $19.99 double
with roses and get a premium vaaz for
$9.99 who does that for you
proflowers.com that's who does it and
your uncle Joey you got to give me some
things I have talked to these people to
get this price beat number two god of
dr. go-to proflowers.com click the
microphone in the upper right corner and
at the promo code Church it's that easy
print the promo code happening happening
H ap PE and ing baby happening so go to
proflowers.com and press in happening on
the microphone on the upper right corner
this is your right hand if you don't
know it's the one on the other side
anyway
enter the promo code happening that's
proflowers.com click the microphone and
use promo code happening it's the 8th
mother's days on the 12th don't wait
order like a bro and get the amazing
rose deal with the vaz for nine nine
nine dollars more 9.99 more and thank
all the moms in your life I want to
thank ProFlowers I want to thank super
crooner I want to thank manscape I want
to thank cake quickly the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for having our back and
supporting our comedy and what we're
trying to do here are cause you know I'm
with you on this [ __ ] thing without
you [ __ ] I got nothing and
that's how it works out so I want to
thank you guys for being part of the
church family all you [ __ ] will
be back Monday morning tip-top Magoo
ready to stab my [ __ ] I suggest you're
ready to go because next week we're
giving our [ __ ] bayonets you
understand me have a great weekend have
a great week and don't forget to stay
black and don't take [ __ ] from nobody
one more time for cake quickly in the
Christ
I gotta go kick this [ __ ] muley